[Música]
Olá pessoal, tudo bem? É um prazer tá
falando com vocês para mais uma live dos
apoiadores aqui do canal.
Bem, vamos lá. Quem está ao vivo
acompanhando? A Irma, boa noite.
Obrigado tá acompanhando ao vivo.
Como é que está o áudio, Irma? Você tá
me escutando bem?
Mais alguém entrou?
Marlon, tudo bem? Boa noite,
Gade Van
Cristina Caru.
Então, vocês estão me ouvindo bem? O
áudio tá legal? Como é que tá?
Ótimo. Vamos começar então aqui começar
a fazer a apresentação.
Deixa eu dividir a tela. aqui
e
pronto.
Primeira pergunta, qual a recomendação
dos principais suplementos para acima
dos 60 anos? Tem um vídeo que eu
publiquei há pouco tempo atrás, tem
poucas semanas, viu? que é sobre o
suplemento para acima de 50 anos de
idade. Então eu vou perguntar, aliás, eu
vou pedir paraa Rosiane
assistir esse vídeo. Se você ficar
alguma dúvida, viu, Rosiane, por favor,
você me pergunta na semana que vem.
Podemos combinar sim. Não sei se a
Rosiane tá ao vivo. Se você tiver ao
vivo, Rosane, por favor, se manifeste,
tá? Vamos partir paraa próxima pergunta.
Por gentileza, doutor, gostaria de saber
suas indicações de auxílio na reposição
hormonal, caso fitoterápico, suplementos
essenciais para mulheres que não tm
indicação de reposição com hormônios
bioidênticos. Desde já agradeço. De
nada.
Com base na literatura científica mais
recente nesses últimos do anos, os
melhores foterápicos que t mais
evidência para suporte hormonal feminino
e vários deles eu uso aqui na clínica é
o Black Rosh, que é a semice pulga
racemosa, que a gente usa de 40 a 80 mg.
é muito bom para fogachos e demais
sintomas vasomotores, que é bem comum na
pessoa na transição, né, no climatério
para menopausa.
Tem a marca peruana também que funciona
com adaptógen, é muito bom para aumentar
testosterona feminina. E a máquina você
usa na faixa de 1500 a 3000 mg por dia.
Ajuda na energia, no libido, na
modulação estrogênica. Temos também o
Vtex Agnuscast. Eu acho esse nome assim,
um nome até poético, né?
Ele ajuda a regular a progesterona, o
TPM.
Tem também a chaganda, a chata
padronizada KSM6
na faixa de 300, 600, 300 a 600 mg por
dia, que é bom para modular o cortisol e
melhorar o sono também, aumenta a
testosterona. E tem a rodiola rosa 200 a
400 mg por dia, também o adaptógeno,
ajuda a controlar a fadiga, melhorar o
humor. E tem o chatavari,
que é da medicina aurveda indiana que
tem, esse eu não tenho experiência, tá?
Esse chatavare não sei que tem no
Brasil.
E é muito importante também ter o básico
bem feito, né? H3, magnésio, vitamina D.
Isso tudo é muito importante também
para mulheres na transição aí da do
climatéria paraa menopausa.
É muito importante ver se a B12 tá OK.
Eh, muitas vezes é importante você repor
o complexo B, que são importantes para
os neurotransmissores.
Vê como é que tá os níveis de zinco, né,
do mineral zinco.
É importante também às vezes tá com
deficiência de zinco.
Então, o protocolo básico seria vitamina
D3 de manhã junto com complexo B, ô3, se
for o caso e magnésio.
De manhã também vai bem rodola rosa e
maca peruana. À noite o magnésio com a
chaganda e maca também.
O black cor roxo que é semice foga
racimosa,
ela controla bem os fogachos
e o vitex agnus castos é bom para TPM
também.
Os efeitos vão demorar de 4 a 12 semanas
para aparecer. Beleza?
Me deem só um instantinho aqui que eu
tenho que fazer um leve ajuste.
Tem umas perguntas que estão chegando
agora de última hora.
Bem, vamos continuar aqui.
Doutor, tem um cortisol matinal salivar
de 7,7
nanomoles por litro. Estou tomando
hidrocortis de 20 mg receita do médico
há 3 meses e vou começar 20 mg de
hidrocortison é uma dose alta, tá? É a
dose máxima, na verdade. E vou começar a
tomar rodola rosa 500 mg e sal integral
na água por conta própria. Mais alguma
dica para ajudar? Então, veja bem, eu
vou dar uma dica, tá? De forma alguma
que a intenção é substituir
a consulta médica. Por favor, tenham
isso em mente, tá?
Bem, primeiramente, cortisol salivar
nessa faixa de 7,7 nanomes.
Você não falou o horário
na é na matinal. Você falou sim,
desculpa, falou matinal. Então, nesse
horário tá realmente abaixo do esperado.
Os valores de referência para de manhã
do corte sol salivá 10 a 27. Então tá
realmente baixo.
Então isso sugere uma insuficiência
relativa adrenal, né? Ou que a gente
chama de disfunção adrenal
e
disfunção do eixo HPA e póspituitário
adrenal
antigamente chamava de fadiga adrenal. A
hidrocortis que você tá tomando 20 mg.
Cuidado, é dose máxima. Isso daí
eu tomaria uma dose um pouco menor, tá?
Tá? E depois você vai desmamando, vai
baixando para 10 e para cinco. Não é bom
ficar mantendo essa dose de 20 mg, que é
praticamente a produção de ar que você
tem o dia inteiro de hidrocortisona.
A tua escolha de adicionar a rodola foi
boa. Sal integral também e os dois vão
ajudar. O sal integral ajuda a regular
audosterona, né, que muitas vezes tá
desregulada e quem tem fadiga de origem
adrenal. A rodiola também é um
adaptógena muito bom,
é um dos mais estudados. Ele atua
diretamente no eixo HPA, ele modula a
liberação de cortisol, tem propriedades
antioxidantes, protege as glândulas
adrenais. O sal integral é fundamental
porque o cortisol baixo faz
eh baixar a pressão arterial, prejudica
a retenção de sódio.
Então esse sal integral vai ajudar eh
nesse sentido, não pode ser um sal
refinado, tá? Então pode ser o sal
Celta, pode ser o sal rosa do Himalaia,
pode ser o sal
marinho integral.
E o horário de tomar esse sal é de manhã
mesmo, junto com a água.
Outra coisa que pode ajudar, que tá
pedindo dicas, vitamina C em altas
doses, uma a 3 g por dia, que a vitamina
C é muito importante para as glândulas
adrenais. Então é importante você tomar
vitamina C em altas doses.
Complexo B, muito importante também e
especialmente a o ácido pantotênico, a
B5. Então tome B5 e altas doses, tá? com
acompanhamento médico. Com um
acompanhamento médico. Então você pode
estar tomando entre 100 a 500 mg de
ácido antotênico, mas tem que tá tendo
acompanhamento médico.
Estudos recentes dizem que 1 g de
vitamina C diariamente pode reduzir o
cortisol quando ele tá alto por conta de
estresse,
mas também é necessário para a síntese
adequada do cortisol quando os níveis
estão baixos. Vitamina C com
bioflavonoides. Aí seria interessante.
Tem aí várias combinações.
Por exemplo, vitamina C mais o rose hips
ou a vitamina C mais quecetina ou a
vitamina C mais rotina. São pode
escolher um flavonoide.
Se o estômago seu for sensível, você
pode usar o ascobato de magnésio,
que ele é uma vitamina C tamponada.
Próxima pergunta. Para antes da próxima
pergunta, deixa eu só fazer um outro
ajuste aqui.
E deem só um instante.
Doutor, não, essa que eu já fiz. Vamos
paraa próxima. Boa noite. Faço
suplementação de diversas vitaminas e
minerais, porém a dosagem da vitamina
B12 tá 665. Atualmente uso duas capas
por dia de meticobolamina 1000 m 1000
microg, né, que dá 1 mg sublingual. Qual
seria a sua
sugestão para melhorar?
Bem, esse nível de B12 tá bom, tá
exatamente na faixa que a gente quer que
entre 550 e 100, tá? Então não tem
problema nenhum.
Tem estudos recentes de 2025 que foram
publicados num jornal chama anals of
Neurology e demonstraram algo
interessante. Tanto níveis muito baixos
quanto níveis excessivamente de B12
elevados podem estar associados
alterações neurológicas. Mas
sinceramente eu nunca vi ter alteração
neurológica com vitamina B12 alta. Mas é
o que o artigo disse,
quando a B2 se liga
predominantemente
a uma proteína de transporte chamado
aptocorrina,
que é uma proteína de transporte
biologicamente inerte,
em níveis muito altos acima de 1500,
podem surgir marcadores de de
neurodoreneração no sangue, portanto não
tem necessidade de aumentar sua
suplementação atual. Você tá na faixa
ótima
e considere reduzir essa dose de 2 mg de
áreo.
Você tomando duas de 1000, né? Então
2000 microg dá 2 mg. Reduza pela metade,
tá? Porque provavelmente a tua vitamina
B12 vai estourar com essa dose.
Se tiver condições, faz uma avaliação
mais completa do seu status funcional de
B12.
a fazendo um exame de
holotranscobalamina,
se tiver acesso a esse exame,
tá? e também do ácido metiumalônico do
sangue, porque esses marcadores nos
dizem se a B12 está realmente chegando
dentro das células e sendo utilizada de
forma adequada,
porque mesmo com níveis séricos
adequados, pode existir uma deficiência
funcional intracelular, especialmente na
presença do estresse oxidativo.
Próxima pergunta.
Urina com cheiro de urina de gato. Essa
pergunta para mim foi bem peculiar. Aí
não me lembro de ter
tido essa pergunta antes.
Não é sempre que ocorre, mas quais são
as possíveis causas? Então eu tô
entendendo então que essa urina tá com
cheiro forte de amônia, né?
Você fala gato, mas na minha casa eu já
senti esse cheiro forte com cachorro,
né?
Ah, tinha um problema lá que tava
acumbulando urina numa
parte ali da sistema hidráulico da casa
e tava dando um cheiro forte de amônia.
Então essa é uma queixa relativamente
comum, geralmente tem causas tranquilas
assim quando ela corre de maneira
intermitente. E a causa mais frequente é
desidratação, porque concentra urina e
aumenta a proporção de uré em relação à
água.
Quando quando auré descompõe, libera
amônia. Então, cria esse odor forte aí
que parece cândida, né? Não sei se esse
é o dor que você tá se referindo.
Se você notar que isso acontece
especialmente após exercícios fortes,
intensos, ou em dias mais quentes ou
quando você bebe água, então a
desidratação é provavelmente a
explicação.
Outras causas possíveis, consumo elevado
de proteínas, especialmente se você
segue uma dieta low carbou cetogênica,
pois quando o corpo metaboliza grandes
quantidades de proteína, ele produz mais
amônia como subproduto.
Alimentos como alho, aspargos e cebola
também podem alterar temporariamente o
odor da urina. O complexo B também pode
dar um cheiro diferente na urina.
Então, se seu doce se tornar persistente
ou tiver outros sintomas acompanhando,
tem que se pensar em outras causas aí.
Pode ser infecção do trato urinário, né?
Infecção
cistite, pode causar dor forte de
amônia, mas aí geralmente tá acompanhado
sintomas, ardência urinar, vontade no
banheiro toda hora ou febre. Problemas
nos insins como insufência renal ou
cálculo nos insins pode resultar em
urina mais concentrada com odor mais
forte devido à dificuldade dos rins em
infiltrar de forma adequada os resíduos.
Doença de fígado também pode dar
problema,
porque o fígado é responsável por
converter amônia em ureia. Então, quando
tem comprometimento do fígado, a amônia
pode se acumular devido à falta de
conversão em ureia e ser eliminado na
urina.
Você precisa desbloquear o iPhone antes.
Eu não tô falando com você, ué.
Então, primeira coisa, aumenta a tua
hidratação, toma mais líquido, dois a 3
L de água por dia e observa se o sintoma
desaparece. Agora, se eu odô persistir
por mais de uma semana, mesmo com boa
hidratação,
aí você tem que passar com média para
fazer uma avaliação com exames, né? uma
bioquímica básica, exame de urina,
cultura de urina, função renal, função
hepática
e pode ser necessário ajustar a ingestão
proteica se você tá comendo carne demais
ou excesso de proteínas animais.
OK?
Então, primeira coisa é bebimentar água.
Deixa eu ver. Eu não tô vendo a
interação de vocês ao vivo aqui.
[Música]
Ah, Rosiane entrou. Eh, dá uma olhada no
vídeo, Rosiane, viu? E aí depois se você
achar que o vídeo, eu vou deixar o link
do vídeo aqui para você.
Se você achar que o vídeo não explicou
tudo que você queria,
a gente responde uma pergunta mais
específica, tá?
Deixa eu mandar para você aqui o link.
Pronto, já gerei o link compartilhado.
Vou pôr um comentário aqui, tá? O link
esse link aqui. OK. Aí você copia e cola
depois assiste o vídeo.
Deixa eu ver as interações ao vivo aqui,
gente. Pergunta que tiver aqui no no
bate-papo, eu vou deixar pro final, tá?
Porque já tem a lista aí do das
perguntas lá do do documento.
Aqui a rima falando que a Maca Ped não
foi maravilhosa para ela.
Opa, a formação aqui, ó.
Maitriveda tem um chatavar no Brasil.
Obrigado pela filmação, Marlo. Eu não,
eu nunca usei
mais vitamina C em altas doses vai
aumentar a produção de oxalato. Não tem
problema nenhum. Só tomar água.
Só tomar água, Marlon. Fácil de
resolver. Não é difícil. Na minha
prática, vitamina C não é um problema
quando a pessoa tá bem hidratada. Nunca
vi ninguém tomar cálculo urinário só
porque tá tomando vitamina C. Geralmente
el não toma água.
Tu tu tu. Tá. E só tem uma pergunta no
documento que eu vou responder mais mais
adiante.
Então, Rafael, se você não pegou ali a
resposta, depois você volta na parte do
vídeo que eu falei isso aí.
Isso. Cadê o like? Tá certo aí, irmão.
Vamos dar like no vídeo.
Vamos continuar aqui.
Doutor, em um vídeo do Cristian Aguiar,
acho que é Cristian o nome dele, né? Ele
cita que mete o folato que no exame de
sangue,
o normal é entre 4 e 22, só que os
níveis ideais são entre 10 e 20. Abaixo
de 10 aumenta homocisteína, aumenta o
risco de depressão. Essa cardiovascular
acima de 20 a 22
aumenta o risco de câncer.
Por favor comentar sobre esse de câncer
com meticolato acima de 22. OK?
Vamos comentar sobre isso.
Então, a literatura científica recente
mostra que a relação entre folato e
câncer é bem mais complexa do que parece
à primeira vista.
Existe o que nós chamamos de paradoxo do
folato. Quanto níveis adequados são
protetores contra o início do câncer,
porque previne danos ao DNA, níveis
muito altos, especialmente acima de 20 a
22, como você comentou aqui, podem
promover a proliferação de células de
lesões préoplásicas
ou células cancerosas que já existam.
Isso foi documentado em estudo sobre
câncer de próstata, onde homens que
tinham um folato férico muito elevado
tiveram maior índice de proliferação
celular tumoral e ensaios clínicos
também randomizados, onde a
suplementação com ácido fólico aumentou
significativamente o risco de adenomas
avançados e câncer de próstata. Qual que
é o mecanismo por trás disso? Tá
relacionado ao papel do folato na
síntese de nucleotídeos e na divisão
celular. Então, as células tumorais têm
uma demanda metabólica muito alta e elas
aproveitam o excesso de folato
disponível para poliferar mais
rapidamente.
Então, eles vão usar esse folato para
síntese de quê? Das
dos tijolinhos que vão ser necessários
para formar o material genético, né? Os
necleotídeos.
Então, estudos recentes em 2024
confirmam que existe um limiar onde o
malefício
e o benefício inverte. Então, um
trabalho foi publicado que mostrou que a
mortalidade por câncer aumenta tanto com
níveis muito baixos quanto com níveis
acima de 23 ng por m. Então, a
preocupação maior historicamente tem
sido com o ácido fórico sintético não
metabolizado, que pode-se acumular no
sangue, inibir enzimas importantes, como
é o caso da timidilatosintase.
Então, no entanto, mesmo comifolato que
é formativa,
níveis cronicamente elevados acima de 22
podem dar substrato excessivo para
células que têm potencial de câncer.
Então é importante ressaltar que essa
associação é mais relevante para quem já
tem lesões pré-neoplásicas,
pré-cancerígenas, ou histórico de
pólipo, adenoma, câncer. Então, paraa
população geral tem essas condições, a
evidência ainda não é conclusiva.
Os estudos mais consistentes mostram o
risco aumentado para câncer de próstata
e possivelmente a denoma de coloção
do Dr. Aguiar de manter os níveis entre
10 a 20 na faixa ideal, evitando a
deficiência e excesso.
Então, se você tiver com níveis acima de
22, pare de tomar temporariamente o
metifolato.
em só um instante.
Próxima pergunta.
Doutor, quais complementos podem ajudar
quem sofre da síndrome de Geogra?
Tem vários aí que podem ajudar.
Me deem só um instante, por favor.
Usado.
Essa pergunta
apareceu do nada aqui. Não tava na minha
lista.
Ah, acho que eu pulei essa pergunta aqui
quando eu fui ver.
Dei só um instante aqui, por gentileza.
Enquanto isso, deixa eu ver aqui as
interações ao vivo. Vai.
Estou fazendo imposição monal com
bioidêntico e cortisol baixo. 10 mg por
dia. Qual que é o tempo máximo adequada
para tomar e desmamando?
Não tem um tempo exato para tomar o
cortisol, não, tá?
Mas
eu tentaria fazer um desmame entre 3 a 6
meses com essa dose. Aí
eu já usei o protocolo da Ra Clark
Credan algumas vezes, tá? Eu sou o
grande fã desse protocolo.
Sim e não. Por que que eu digo sim e
não? Porque tem coisas muito boas no
protocolo da Roda Clark. Agora eu acho
que é necessário todo mundo fazer
protocolo de ruda clar para
dispararizar. Não acho. Acho que isso é
um exagero,
tá?
Eu acho que é muito mais simples tomar
um antiparasitário comum mesmo.
Bem, vamos à pergunta do jogando
sobre suplementos, certo? Que que é
acima de jogo, né? É uma condição
autoimune que é muito desafiadora. Ela
afeta as grandas lacrimais e salivares,
deixa a pessoa com dificuldade de emitir
lágrimas e a boca fica seca.
Então é olho seco boca seca. E baseado
na literatura mais recente, os
suplementos mais promissores,
vitamina D em altas doses pode ser
tentado, né, que muitas doenças
autoimunes ela resolve. É o protocolo
coimbra, né, o famoso protocolo coimbra.
Então
eu tentaria usar aí ou por volta de
20.000 unidades por dia de vitamina D ou
até dos mais alta 50.000, 100.000. Aí
vai depender muito da resposta inicial.
Eu começaria com 20.000, avaliaria o
PTH, avaliaria o cálcio na urina, o
magnésio na urina.
E a resposta clínica e se não for
suficiente, a gente subir a dose para
deixar o PTH na faixa de 10 a 12, que é
diferente da faixa de 20 a 30, que eu
recomendo para as pessoas que não tm
doença autoimune, tá?
Então quando o PTH tá muito suprimido,
significa que a vitamina D tá muito
alta. Então é o critério que a gente usa
para tratar doença autoimune com
vitamina D. Ômega-3 é importante a que
tá tomando entre 2 a 3 g ao dia.
Tem estudos mostrando que omôme3 melhora
a produção de lágrimas, melhora a
inflamação sistêmica,
melhora o fluxo salivar, lactoferrina
oral também interessante numa dose de
270 mg.
melhora a parte da córnea,
melhora o filme lacrimal.
Tem também o extrato de Macberry, tá?
Macberry é uma dessas berries aí menos
conhecida.
Isso é uma coisa mais recente. São
estudos japoneses mostrando que 60
mgberry
pode aumentar a produção lacrimal em
quase 48% após 60 dias de uso.
O NAC também ajuda aumentando a gluta
melhoradora ocular, irritabilidade dos
olhos,
complexo B ajuda.
Vitamina C e também ajuda funcionando
como antioxidantes potentes.
Você pode usar também antiinflamatórios
naturais, cocumina,
quercetina,
teve resultados promissores em estudos
recentes.
A cucumina reduziu a infiltração da
célula de defesa linfócitos nas
glândulas salivares. A quecetina também
teve efeito regulando a via de
sinalização da leptina, melhorou a
poptose, a inflamação glandular. Os
probióticos também ajudam porque os
pacientes tô, ele geralmente tem
microbioma, microbioma oral menos
diversificado,
tem maior risco de problemas dentários,
então é uma abordagem multifatorial, né?
Lembrando que tem que tirar o glúten,
tem que tirar a casina, né, que é o
derivado do leite, que vai ter os
melhores resultados.
A próxima pergunta.
Doutor, estou preste a iniciar a
suplementação com a AKG, a AKG, que é o
argenina alfautarato,
mais ácido deaspártico e elitrulina
malato prescrita para aumento de vaso
dilatação
da disposição e p falsa muscular.
Pergunto, funciona mesmo? Que outros
benefícios posso ter? E uma pergunta
técnica, um professor de bioquímica me
falou que os isômeros d de aminoácidos
não tm função no nosso organismo. É
verdade. É o os que tm função é o L, tá?
O que dizer sobre D asparto.
Então, essa questão do AKG, eu já passei
pro paciente, tá?
para essa questão aí de performance de
esporte muscular.
A questão é que a literatura tem
evidências mistas aí alguns estudos têm
mostrado pequenos ganhos de força máxima
e de potência anaeróbica e os estudos
mais recentes, inclusive uma revisão de
2024 mostrou que ele não aumenta
significativamente o fluxo sanguíneo
durante o exercício como era a
propaganda. Então, o ácido de aspártico
ele é ainda mais problemático para
pessoas treinadas,
porque estudos de 2015 a 2025 mostraram
que ele não aumenta a testosterona em
atletas, como se pensava,
e em dose de 6 g pode até reduzir os
níveis almonais devido a mecanismo de
feedback negativo. Então, a Litrulina
malato é o componente mais promissor que
tem nessa fórmula. Eu uso muito
citrulina aqui na na clínica com
evidências consistentes de melhora na
produção do óxido nítrico. Vai reduzir a
fadiga muscular e a dor pós treino,
embora os efeitos sobre vasos dilatação
durante o exercício não são tão
expressivos como a gente imaginava.
Então você vai provavelmente notar
alguma melhora na recuperação, uma
redução na fadiga por causa do efeito da
citrulina, né, que vai aumentar o óxido
nítrico. O malato também vai ajudar no
ciclo de crebes, aumentando a energia,
melhorando a produção de ATP, porém não
espere ganhos dramáticos de força. Aí a
creatina para isso tem muito mais de
tudo evidência. também não espera
hipertrofia,
porque os estudos não sustentam essas
promessas. Eu passar, passei por um
tempo isso daí, depois eu parei de
passar porque era uma coisa meio cara e
não tinha tanto resultado mesmo. Então a
vaso dilatação pode ocorrer, mas de uma
maneira mais sutil do que eles anunciam.
Então, se você busca efeitos mais
consistentes para performance,
aí você pode estar usando doses maiores
de citrulina malato
isoladamente, né, sem o os outros, entre
8 a 10 g. Isso tem mais suporte
científico do que a combinação do Aak e
o D asparto.
Agora aquela questão lá do L e do D, tá?
A maioria dos aminoácidos no organismo
são L, sim, tá? Só que o D aspartato e a
decerina são exceções, tá?
O deaspartato e a decerina t funções
biológicas em mamíferos.
O debatato com neuromodulador do sistema
nervoso central.
Liga-se o famoso do receptor NMDA, que
são receptores de glutamato e regula a
síntese de hormônios no eixo potamo,
hipófise gonadal, e também tá envolvido
na formação de espermato
de espermatozoides, né, esmatogênes.
Então o deasparto, ele é sintetizado no
organismo pela enzima aspartemase
e degradado pela deaspartidase. Então
existe alguns aminoácidos D, tá?
Não são todos que são L, mas a maioria
L.
L eh e D tem a ver com a
biologia molecular
de posição 3D, tá? Posição no espaço. O
D virado pra direita, o L virado pra
esquerda.
Faz mais de um ano que sinto que meu
estômago não digere bem os alimentos. Já
usei enzimas digestivas, 100 de
tripsina, 200 de betaína,
100 de amilase, lipase, pancreatina,
bromelaína, lactase e tintura de
aleclínicos, pieira santa e guastatonga,
mas não me ajudou. O que posso fazer?
Gente, eu vou dar a dica aqui. Vocês têm
que procurar consulta, tá? Não é
consulta médica aqui.
Pela minha experiência, pela literatura,
quando as enzimas digestivas e os
fitoterápicos não estão resolvendo o
problema, geralmente é uma questão mais
profunda que tem que ser investigada. E
você faria um compromx, um compróico
estendido, né, para poder investigar
melhor isso. A despepsia funcional é uma
coisa muito comum, afeta por volta de
30% da população do do planeta, é
frequentemente associado à
hipocloridria, que é falta de ácido
clorídico no estômago,
também a infecção pro Hapilore e o
supercrescimento bacteriano, cibo, né?
Então, essas condições interferem no
processo digestório, fazendo com que os
alimentos não sejam adequadamente
quebrados e digeridos e pode dar aquela
sensação de estômago cheio, pesado e
gases.
Primeira coisa a se fazer sem
investigação do intestino
mais apurada,
então fazer o compromax que lá do lemos
ou um exame parecido com compromax que
vai paraos Estados Unidos, que são os
CDSA, né, os comprehensive digested
analysis,
fazer um teste para capilor seria
interessante
que pode ser tanto por endoscopia
como um exame de feses ou teste
respiratório, porque o hpiló ele
neutraliza o ácido do estômago.
e pode ser causa do da gastrite
atrófica.
Então é importante também avaliar a
possibilidade do cibo pelo teste
respiratório, né, que usa eh lactulose,
é o teste respiratório de hidrogênio e
metano,
porque abaixo de acidez no estômago
predispõe ao crescimento bacteriano
anormal do intestino delgado.
E se houver disponibilidade, o teste de
Heidelberg, né, pode medir diretamente o
pH gásco para confirmar a hipocoridria.
Então você pode estar usando o
cloridrato betaína com pepsina, as
refeições principais até você conseguir
fazer essa investigação, começando com
doses baixas
e aumentando aos poucos.
Mas só faça isso se você não tiver
histórico de úlceras gástricas ou
dorenais.
Evite o glúten, os derivados do leite,
porque eles aumentam a inflamação
intestinal e dificultam a digestão.
Prefira refeições menores e mais
frequentes,
com proteínes de alta qualidade,
gorduras boas. Mastigue muito bem a sua
comida. Isso é uma coisa que muita gente
esquece. mastigue pelo menos 20 vezes a
comida antes de digerir, antes de
engolir, né? E pode também pensar em
zincarnosina,
que tem mostrado excelentes resultados
na restauração da mucosa gástrica.
E muitas vezes tem que tratar a gapilore
e o tratamento da gapilore resolve o
problema também. E se tiver cibo, às
vezes tem que usar antibiótico, tanto
natural quanto de farmácia, né?
Afaximina é uma opção e tem também as
combinações de fitoterápicos como
extrato de alho, extrato de
orégano, mais outros agentes, né? Tem
pau d'arco, tem um monte de agentes aí
que pode utilizar.
Beleza?
Você
citou na live 36 causas que precisam ser
tratadas para curar o declínio
cognitivo. Então o recorde não trata só
no recorde não deve ser recode, né? Não
trata só no Alzheimer em si, mas o
declínio de forma geral. Sim, o
protocolo recode não é só para
Alzheimer, é para prevenção também de
def cognitivo, tá?
e declina o cognitivo de maneira mais
ampla se tiver no começo.
Então o Dr. Dale Brads identificou mais
de 36 fatores que contribuem pro decim
cognitivo que vão desde desequilíbrios
hormonais, deficiências nutricionais,
inflamação crônica, resistência a
insulina, exposição a toxinas,
infecções crônicas, inclusive da boca,
até problemas de sono e estresse
oxidativo. Então, a doença de Alzheimer
é o resultado final de um desequilíbrio
entre os sinais que promovem crescimento
e os sinais que criam a degeneração, né,
a o desfazimento lá da sinapses.
Então, quando múltiplos desses 36
fatores estão desregulados, o cérebro
entra em modo de downsizing, ou seja,
ele começa a reduzir as suas conexões.
Isso leva ao declínio incognitivo
progressivo.
Então, eu já fiz essa analogia várias
vezes aí, inclusive na live de ontem à
noite que nós fizemos com o Rodrigo 25.
Então, imagine um telhado que tem 36
buracos
e você precisa tampar o máximo possível
de buracos para parar o vazamento.
Então, não adianta tampar apenas um ou
dois dos buracos.
Então, o recode se aplica muito bem
desde o comprometimento cognitivo leve,
subjetivo até os estágios mais iniciais
de Alzheimer, não vai funcionar muito
bem para estágio avançado. Quanto mais
precoce você identificar e corrigir
esses equilíbrios, melhor vai ser os
resultados.
E é um protocolo de medicina de
precisão, de medicina individualizada,
com os princípios funcionais que nós
precisamos aplicar individualmente em
cada pessoa para corrigir os
desequilíbrios.
É importante entender que não existe uma
pílula mágica para essa doença. O
caminho é esse mesmo, infelizmente mais
complicado, mas esse é o caminho.
Essa é uma mudança de paradigma que tem
que ser feita na medicina de modo geral.
É muito importante abordar todos esses
fatores ao mesmo tempo. Atividade
física, nutrição, jejum, sono,
otimização hormonal, suporte
mitocondrial, redução de inflamação de
toxinas.
Porque o sucesso de tratamento depende
desses fatores.
Doutor, em discussões,
as em virtude das discussões no grupo
relacionando vitamina D e cálculos
renais, será que este seria um assunto
relevante para um novo vídeo no canal? É
algo que não se fala da questão de
realizar o exame de origem de 4 horas,
de verificar o PTH, de utilizar magnésio
ou potássio se trata, entre outras
informações que não são difundidas.
Fica a sugestão. Podemos fazer um vídeo.
Eu não sei se eu eu faria esse vídeo
na parte aberta, não, tá? Eu vou
explicar para vocês porquê.
Recentemente, nas últimas quatro
semanas, deu uma melhorada nas
visualizações do canal. E por que que
melhorou?
porque eu tive que mudar as minhas
estratégias, né?
Não adianta ficar brigando com o
algoritmo do YouTube. Então, tem alguns
assuntos que não dá para falar na área
aberta. Não tô nem falando aqui de
questão aí de censura, não. É porque
simplesmente ferra o algoritmo. O, a
plataforma não entrega o vídeo para as
pessoas.
Muitas pessoas entram no vídeo, acham o
vídeo chato e sai logo no começo. Isso
atrapalha demais a divulgação, a
propagação do vídeo.
Então a gente tem que trabalhar com
coisas populares, não tem jeito. Então
se eu avaliar que esse tema não tem
lugar na comunidade aberta, eu ponho na
fechada. Simples assim, entendeu?
A relação entre vitamina D e cálculos
renais é relevante, mas não é tão
simples como se diz. gera muita confusão
porque tem uma aparente contradição na
literatura. Tem estudos que falam que a
suplementação com a vitamina D poderia
aumentar a calciúura, ou seja, o cálcio
na urina e o cálcio no sangue. Mas eu
não acredito nisso. E as metaanálises
mais recentes não encontraram aumento
consistente na formação de cálculos
renais por causa da suplementação com
vitamina D.
De 2024 para cá, o que tem aparecido é
que os indivíduos predispostos, né, que
t hipercalciúria, ou seja, muito cálcio
na urina por conta de absorção
aumentada,
esse pessoal aí que pode ter risco
aumentado quando recebe doses mais altas
e vitamina D, aí a dieta é o ponto
principal e se essa pessoa tem calciura
absorível,
a questão que a maioria dos
profissionais, eles prescrevem vitamina
D sem solicitar urâ de 24 horas para
avaliar a calciúria de base e não dosam
também o paratormônio. Então esses
exames são muito importantes paraa gente
possa verificar quem tem maior risco e
não deveria tomar vitamina D naquele
momento.
Então é muito importante a dosagem do
paratormônio PTH, que eu já falei aqui
na live,
porque níveis elevados de PTH muitas
vezes pode ser hiperparatiroidismo
primário.
O hiperparatiroidismo secundário é
quando a o PTH tá alto por falta de
vitamina D, mas existe também o
hiparatiroidismo
primário, que é porque as glândulas lá e
as paratireoides estão produzindo PTH
demais. Então tem que tomar muito
cuidado porque se a pessoa tiver
hiperparaprimário, não pode tomar
vitamina D até resolver o
hiperparaprimário,
pelo menos em doses mais altas. E é
importante também associar o magnésio e
o citrato de potássio que vão proteger,
vão ajudar a prevenir a formação de
cálculos, porque vão modificar o pH
urinário e vão diminuir a cristalização
do oxalato que forma pedra,
certo?
Agora, se houver interesse suficiente de
todo mundo, aí a gente faz um um um
vídeo, eu faço um vídeo na comunidade
fechada, não precisa ser uma live sobre
esse assunto, tá? Mas eu acho que esse
assunto não vai caber bem na comunidade
aberta, não vai bagunçar o algoritmo.
Dr. Alan, uma pessoa que não fazmentação
de vitamina B12, B9, porém como se tenda
inferior a cinco, é normal, preocupante
algo que necessado?
Sim, uma alta é um problema, mas muito
baixa também é um problema.
Então, a literatura diz que níveis muito
baixos deina,
especialmente abaixo de cinco ou seis,
tá associado a condições como
desnutrição,
disfunção hepática,
hipertiroidismo
e síndrome de mosção.
Tem um estudo aí de Taiwan de 2021 que
mostrou que pessoas com sistína abaixo
de seis tinham pior percepção da própria
saúde. E teve um outro estudo europeu em
doses hospitalizados que mostrou que
níveis baixos sem suplementação estaria
associado à desnutrição,
falta de albumina, né, no sangue e maior
mortalidade.
A onina, ela é um produto intermediário
que tá envolvido em várias vias
bioquímicas aí relacionadas a
metabolismo da betonina.
E a betonina é o aminoácido essencial,
nós obtemos através da alimentação
proteica. Então, quando alguém come
pouca proteína ou proteína de menos,
pode terna muito baixa.
Isso nós estamos contando pessoas que
não suplementam o complexo B, OK? que a
próprio complexo B pode baixar um
citina,
então tem ficar de olho. Se não tá
comendo pouca proteína, isso pode ser a
causa da uncênina baixa.
Outra possibilidade é o fígado tá
ferrado, né? Uma disfunção hepática,
porque o fígado é o principal órgão
responsável pelo metabolismo da
homociteína.
O hipertiriidismo também pode causar
níveis reduzidos por causa da aceleração
do metabolismo e mutações genéticas
raras em enzimas envolvidos no ciclo da
meteonina também são causa possível de
baixa oxisteina.
Então é importante avaliar a função
tirodiana completa, função hepática,
ver albumina, né, que também tem a ver
com a função hepática,
que também é um marcador de estado
nutricional.
Vê se a ingestão proteica tá adequada.
Verificar se não tem mutações do GNTHFR.
OK.
Qual a tua opinião sobre hemoterapia? Eu
acho que você tá dizendo de hemo
ao autoemoterapia.
Deve ser isso tá falando, né? Vou
entender dessa maneira. Você tá ao vivo,
Thaago? Deixa eu ver,
Thaago está ao vivo ou não?
Peptis Strong é bom. Eh, só meio
carinho, tá?
Eu acho que ele não tá aqui. Mas vamos
lá.
Então, vou entender que você tá falando
de autoemoterapia, tá? Eh, não tenho
certeza se isso quis dizer.
O que que é autohemoterapia sem ozônio?
A que é feita muitas vezes até dentro de
casa, né? O pessoal faz sozinho aí.
O pessoal tira o sangue da veia e coloca
dentro do músculo. Esse sangue não passa
por nenhum tratamento, nenhum processo.
E existe a isso aí chamada
autoemoterapia menor, né? e tem
autoemoterapia com ozônio. Então aí você
tira o sangue, ozoniza e devolve no
músculo quando é autoemoterapia menor.
Existe também autoemoterapia maior que
você tira um 100 ml de sangue numa
bolsinha com uma bolsa de transfusão,
mistura com 100 ml de ozônio e devolve
esse sangue na veia.
Quando o sangue é exposto ao médico, né,
que é mais oxigênio do que ozônio,
ocorre uma cascata de reações
bioquímicas ativa uma via chamado NRF2,
que é a mesma via que estimula pelo
exercício físico, também pelo jejum.
Então isso aumenta a produção de enzimas
antioxidantes, é o caso da superóxido
desmutáe.
Aumenta a glutatina da peroxidase também
outro enzima antioxidante aumenta a
catalase também. Isso quando o ozônio
não tá em dose muito alta, quando tá na
faixa de mais ou menos 20 micra.
Agora, em relação ao risco de
desenvolver doença autoimune, os estudos
mais recentes mostram o contrário, tá?
Porque se você tá falando do autoemo com
ozônio, porque o ozônio tem um efeito
imunomodulador, ele equilibra o sistema
imunológico em vez de simplesmente
estimular. Então tem pesquisas recentes
aí do ano passado que mostram melhora
significativa pacientes que têm
esclerose múltipla, artrite reumatoide,
lupus, jogren e outras doenças
autoimunes. O mecanismo é através da
redução das células TH17
e das citocinas pró-inflamatórias, é o
caso de teleocina 17 e 23, são
justamente as responsáveis pela
progressão das doenças autoimunes. Então
o ozônio ele combate a doção imunoca.
Então ele é imunomodulador, porque se a
pessoa tiver também imunossupressão, o
ozone vai estimular o sistema imune.
Mas em caso de hiperatividade ele vai
acalmar a resposta inflamatória
excessiva. Então ele é um regulador.
Quando precisa aumentar ele aumenta,
quando precisa baixar ele baixa.
O ozone é extremamente seguro se for
aplicado por uma pessoa minimamente
treinada.
pode ter efeitos colaterais. É o caso da
reação tipo Hheimer,
que acontece quando o sistema imune tá
ativado
e começa a eliminar os patógenos e
começa a ter liberações temporárias e de
toxinas.
Não pode fazer ozônio quem tem favismo,
que é a deficiência do glicose fosfato
de hidrogenase. Quem tem hipertiroidismo
descompensado,
grávidas degestantes,
quem tem distúbios hemorrágicos agudos
ou quem tá usando anticoante em altas
doses.
E a autoemoterapia sem ozônio tem muito
menos evidência científica, mas muita
gente jura de pé junto que funciona.
Tenho visto muitos depoimentos de
pessoas colocando atrite reumatoide
emissão pelo protocolo Coimbra.
Algumas dessas pessoas dizem que em
determinado momento deram uma
escapadinha na alimentação e comeram
glúteo. No dia seguinte, mesmo estando
em remissão, sentiram dores nas
articulações. Porém, 24 horas depois as
dores subiram. O castigo do glúteo foi
muito rápido, mesmo estando em remissão.
As outras doenças autoimunes também
castigam rápido ao comer gluten, mesmo
estando em remissão. Ou isso é uma
particularidade da artrite reumatoide.
Bem, estudos recentes mostram que essa
resposta inflamatória veloz não é uma
particularidade da artritumatoide, é um
padrão comum a várias doenças
autoimunes,
especialmente pacientes em remissão que
estão fazendo o protocolo coimbra.
Então, quando o gluto entra em contato
com a mucosa do intestino, ele se liga a
um receptor lá nas células epiteliais,
ele desencadeia a liberação imediata da
zonulina, aquela proteína que aumenta a
permeabilidade intestinal.
E isso acontece rápido em questão de 1 a
2 horas.
Isso permite a passagem de peptídios,
que são
cadeias de minoácidos curtas
do glúten e outras substâncias
pró-inflamatórias que vão pra corrente
sanguínea. Então esse aumento de
peribilidade leva a produção rápida de
citocinas inflamatórias, o caso do
telocina 6 das 17 do TNF alfa.
Isso pode causar sintomas articulares
em até 24 horas. Isso pode acontecer
também com lupos. esse cartípo rápido aí
do glúten, né? Tidatimoto, psoríase,
esclerose múltipla, diabético um.
Então, estudos mostram que mesmo
pacientes que remissão mantém uma
resposta mais rápida, intensa ao glúten,
comparado a pessoas sem doenças
autoimunes.
A diferença é que quando você tá em
remissão com doses altas de vitamina D
protocolo coimbra, o sistema de defesa,
sistema imune estará mais regulado e
consegue se recuperar mais rapidamente
da agressão pelo glúten. E por isso que
os sintomas desaparecem em pouco tempo.
24, 48 horas.
Então, a modulação imune da vitamina D
permite uma recuperação mais acelerada.
E no caso atriteatoide entre as dois
autoimunes, pode ser que seja mais
perceptível
essa melhora, né? Ou essa piora melhora
quando tira o glúten ou piora quando
coloca o glúten, porque as articulações
são estruturas que manifestam inflamação
de forma muito evidente, muito dolorosa,
né? né? Chamou muita atenção,
mas o processo inflamatório do glúten
afeta todas as doenças autoimunes.
Então, por isso que no protocolo
coimbra, apesar que eu conheço alguns
profissionais que aplicam o protocolo
que dizem que não precisa parar o
glúten, não concordo. No meu
entendimento, tem que ter uma restrição
do glút e não é opcional, seria
fundamental para manter a remissão,
porque cada exposição glút
geraria aí um pico inflamatório que,
embora temporário,
poderia comprometer os resultados do
tratamento a longo prazo.
Fiquei sabendo que dá-se o nome de
síndrome múltiplo autoimune é um acúmulo
de três ou mais condições autoimunes.
Pegar água aqui, pessoal, pera aí.
O motivo pelo qual a pessoa vai
acumulando doenças autoimunes com o
passar do tempo é porque ela não faz o
devido tratamento
e por isso a quantidade doença
autoimunes vai aumentando.
Bem, a resposta não é tão simples, viu?
que a gente sabe pela literatura
que aproximadamente 25% dos pacientes
com uma doença autoimune tem tendência a
desenvolver outras condições autoimunes.
Eu já vi até estatística de 50%.
Isso ao longo da vida, né? Porque essa
pessoa tem fatores de suscetibilidades,
né?
Existem genes de suscetibilidade
que são compartilhados entre as doenças
autoimunes,
especialmente variações do HLA, que é um
sistema de antígenos leucocitários,
o HLA DRB1,
além de alterações no expossoma, que é o
conjunto de exposições ambientais ao
longo da vida.
Isso inclui disbiose do
microbiointestinal,
infecções como citomalvírus, estresses,
toxinas e alterações alimentares.
Então o acúmulo de doenças autoimunes
tem razões, raízes aí muito mais
profundas do que simplesmente a ausência
de tratamento.
Então é muito importante o tratamento
adequado da primeira doença autoimune,
mas ela, esse tratamento não garante que
outras não vão se desenvolver.
A evidência diz que pacientes com
síndrome múltipla autoimune geralmente
tem um curso mais grave da doença, maior
comprometimento orgânico,
independentemente do tratamento. Então,
pesquisa 2024 indicam que é uma janela
crítica para intervenção precoce e
detecção de biomarcadores
pré-autoimunes,
onde o controle de fatores modificáveis,
como é o caso da hiperperabilidade
intestinal, ligado ao glúten, a caseína,
né, os alimentos processados,
industrializados e agrotóxicos,
que vão levar a níveis elevados do
nulina e também tem a ver com as
bactérias da disbiose, o excesso de
bactérias que vai liberar
lipopolissaacarídos que fazem parte da
parede bacteriana na corrente sanguínea.
Então, mesmo quando tem um tratamento
imunospressor
convencional ortodoxo otimizado,
existe aí uma predisposição genética e
os gatilhos ambientais, se não forem
removidos, vão levar a segunda doença
autoimune em muitos casos.
Então é importante focar no ambiente,
né, no expossoma.
É importante otimizar a saúde
intestinal, controlar a permeabilidade
intestinal, modular o microbioma, fazer
a suplementação com vitamina D, zinco,
magnésio, tudo que for necessário,
redução da carga tóxica ambiental, comer
orgânico,
ter a preocupação de tirar os alimentos
processados, refinados,
industrializados.
Controle rigoroso de gatilhos
inflamatórios alimentares.
Tudo isso é importante para reduzir o
risco da segunda doença autoimune.
Então, não espere a segunda doença
autoimune chegar. Se tiver uma doença
autoimune, faça essas medidas que nós
estamos conversando aqui, que é muito
mais eficaz do que ficar esperando a
doença aparecer, né? que fica muito mais
difícil de tratar depois.
Aqui tem duas perguntas e um. Por que
que não separou, né? Vamos lá.
O ideal é consumir uma refeição. Quanto
tempo depois de fazer musculação? Eu não
sei o que quer dizer o ideal aqui no que
sentido você tá querendo dizer. Você se
você terminou de fazer atividade física,
poderia comer em qualquer momento
depois, tá? Você não vai passar mal de
comer logo em seguida.
Se você tá falando daquela janela
anabólica que o pessoal falava que tinha
que ter refeição 30 minutos após o
treino, senão seu músculo não cresce,
isso já caiu por terra, tá? Mas foi um
mito que ficou muito tempo aí, mas já
caiu. A janela real é muito mais longa.
Você pode ficar várias horas sem comer e
mesmo assim, se você ingerir a proteína,
você vai ter o ganho anólico.
Essa janela ideal, digamos assim, é de 4
a 6 horas depois da do exercício, mas
tem estudo falando que mesmo você coma
10 horas depois, você pode ter ganho
ainda.
mais importante realmente é a ingestão
proteica total ao longo do dia, que tem
que ficar na faixa de 1,6 a 2,2 g por kg
de peso corporal. Essa intenção é
hipertrofia.
Então, se você consome uma refeição
adequada com proteína e carboidrato
mesmo horas depois do do treino, não tem
problema nenhum.
Tem v necessidade de sair correndo não.
OK.
É só garantir que a quantidade diária de
proteína tá adequada. Próxima pergunta
aqui. Na live que você fez com o Dr. Gil
Cossergins, ele disse que não é bom
consumir alimento antioxidante depois da
musculação. Quanto tempo depois?
Então, a razão
de você não consumir o antioxidante logo
depois da atividade física é que a lesão
que você teve, microlesão que você teve,
o estímulo muscular que você teve do
exercício, ele vai provocar o quê?
liberação
de radicais livres, espécies ativas de
oxigênio pelo exercício intenso.
E se for uma quantidade de radicais
livres adequada, não for excessiva, eles
funcionam como sinalizadores celulares
que vão ativar vias importantes
bioquímicas, a MPK,
o PGC1
Alfa, o MK, que são vias interessantes
na biogênese mitocondrial, ou seja, vai
aumentar a quantidade de mitocôndrias,
vai aumentar a síntese proteica
e melhorar a sensibilidade insulina.
E se você consumir muito antioxidante
dose alta depois do treino, você vai
cortar essa cascata bioquímica, você vai
bloquear sinalizações benéficas e vai
perder ganho.
Então evite antioxidantes
entre duas a 3 horas antes do treino
também duas a 3 horas depois do treino,
OK? para acontecer a sinalização
celular, que vai ser importante para
ativar as cascatas de adaptação celular.
Então, evite nac, vitamina C, vitamina E
nas 3 horas seguidas ao treino.
Doutor, litcite de 1080 mg custa cerca
de R$ 80 por set cápsulas. Um pacote
central de potássio padrão alimentício
de 1 kg custa R$ 70,
mas o custo encapsulado de R$ 70 para
confeccionar cerca de 1000 cápsulas de
1000 mg.
É possível a substituição?
possível é possível é,
mas existe uma diferença real entre o
grau farmacêutico da manipulação e o
grau alimentício
que você vai obter na internet.
Então, se você conseguir o grau
farmacêutico
que nos Estados Unidos chama USP, ele
tem uma pureza acima de 99%
e tem controle mais rigoroso de
contaminantes,
especialmente os metais pesados.
O grau alimentício não é 99, não é acima
de 99. Na verdade, o grau alimentício
vai ser 98 a 99%.
Mas as regulamentações tanto aqui quanto
os Estados Unidos são mais flexíveis
quanto aos níveis aceitáveis de
impurezas.
Então podem ter partículas metálicas,
outros contaminantes
que não seriam permitidos em produtos
farmacêuticos.
E tem estudos que mostram isso, tá? que
existe contaminação por metais pesados
nesses suplementos alimentares que não
são grau farmacêutico.
E outra coisa, se você fazer o
encapsulamento caseiro,
eu tô entendendo que esse encapsulamento
é caseiro, né?
Você
pode ter um problema, mesmo que você
adquira um citrato de potássio de grau
alimentício, de boa procedência,
o processo de capsulação em casa manual,
você pode aí causar contaminação
cruzada, pode ter exposição à umidade,
porque o se trato de potássio pega
umidade, né, que a gente chama de
igroscópico.
Você não vai ter um controle de
qualidade sobre o peso exato por
cápsula.
E outra coisa, as cápsulas vazias que
você compra para encapsulamento caseiro,
elas não têm a mesma garantia de pureza
e ausência de contaminantes que as
cápsulas farmacêuticas.
Então, a minha argomentação você
utilizar ou litocite
ou citrato de potássio manipulado, não
utilizar ele comprado assim de fontes
alimentícias, tá? Especialmente
se você tá utilizando para alcalinizar
urina ou para tratar pedra nos insins.
Essa economia que vai dar uns 50% de
economia, não entendo ela que seja
suficiente para justificar os riscos
potenciais.
assistir os seus vídeos de tocoferid e
tocotrenois e também de vitamina E mais
recente. Tenho 52 anos, minha esposa 48.
Suplementamos há anos magnésio, vitamina
D, K2, zinco, cobre, selen meteorina.
Não temos nenhuma patologia
diagnosticada e praticamos atividade
física. Estou com dificuldade de
encontrar um bom suplemento de vitamina
E.
O Natural Max é uma boa opção, tá?
Que é uma
fonte de urucum
os tocotrienóis.
O Naturx ele é um precipativo que as
manipulações compram.
Se você não achar o Natromax, tem os
tocotrienois
extraídos da palma também.
E os mais importantes tocotrenóis é o
Delta e o gama,
que são ricos no urucum,
que vão ter mais estudos aí mostrando
melhora de saúde cardiovascular,
cerebral, proteção com LDL oxidado,
tá? Então, Naturomax, tô com trenois de
urucum, 300 ou 400 mg por dia. Você pode
dividir em duas tomadas com efeitos com
gordura porque ele é lipolúvel.
Se não achar esse, você usa da do óleo
de palma, tá? Que o tocotrenol é melhor
que o alfa trocferol para a saúde geral.
Caramba, tá faltando ainda seis
perguntas. A gente já passou de uma hora
de live aqui.
Eu acho que eu vou ter que fazer as as
respostas mais rápidas. Eu tô eu tô
tomando muito tempo em cada pergunta
aqui.
Pensar nisso na próxima aí.
Todos os marcadores inflamatórios
normais só pertido em 430. Indicador de
hemocromatose? Depende, Cleidivan,
depende. Pode ser sim, pode ser que não,
tá?
Na maior parte das vezes não é, porque
hemocromato geralmente afetina é acima
de 1000,
tá?
É mais inflamação mesmo. Ou excesso de
ferro na alimentação. Aí tem que cortar
carne vermelha.
e ingerir aí arroz negro ou arroz
vermelho para ir que quelando os metais,
né? Quelando o ferro da alimentação.
Pode usar também ferro homeopático 30
para ajudar a eliminar ferro na urina.
Ventosa tem realmente eficácia em dores
e inflamação? Tem. Eu já fiz ventosa. É
da medicina chinesa.
Ela tem eficácia real? Sim.
Teve uma revisão sistemática desse ano,
2025, que analisou 72 estudos,
muita gente, 5700 indivíduos e mostrou
efeitos benéficos na ventosa em dor
crônica. Por isso que é usado até em,
você deve ter visto já em Olimpíadas
passadas o pessoal aquelas marcas das
ventosas. Então, realmente funciona,
viu?
A ventosa, ela aumenta o fluxo sanguíneo
local, estimula reflexos neurológicos,
ativa
a o portão da dor, aumenta a produção de
piodides endógenos do cérebro, modula a
resposta inflamatória.
Então, estudos recentes com ultrassom e
elastografia, que é um tipo de técnica
que usa no ultrassom, mostraram que
diferentes pressões negativas conseguem
reduzir rigidez, melhor oxigenação
tecidual e regula marcadores
inflamatórios.
Então, funciona assim,
mas não usar isoladamente, tá?
O uso da vitamina D3 tem relação com
cálculo renal. Eh, eu vou fazer, como
essa pergunta tá tá repetindo, eu vou
fazer um vídeo paraa comunidade fechada
sobre isso, tá?
Mas a resposta rápida é o seguinte:
se você bebe água suficiente e não tem
uma dieta lixo, a vitamina D não vai ser
a causa de cálculo renal.
Agora, se você tiver lixo, tiver com
deficiência de magnésio
e não tiver tomando água, aí sim a
vitamina D pode contribuir para a
formação de pedra.
Os grandes estudos prospectivos que
t.000
participantes não mostraram associação
entre ingestão de vitamina D e des pedra
noss.
Mas use com H2, use com magnésium que e
não coma porcaria para você evitar
hipercalciúria.
A dieta comum já tem muito cálcio, então
tem que tomar muito cuidado com isso.
Então, por exemplo, pessoas estão
tomando vitamina D, tem que evitar a
suplementação de cálcio
se não tiver uma indicação clara que
precisa fazer suplementação de cálcio.
Então
eu acho que ficou claro, né? Se não se
não tiver você tá ao vivo, Credivan? Não
sei. Vamos ver.
Eu acho que não. Ah, não. Tá sim. Ele tá
ao vivo aqui. Esclareceu, Credivan, a
tua dúvida.
Quando se orienta ao praticante de
musculação com de 3 horas, intervalo de
3 horas por conta-se do início da
primeira refeição para o início da
segunda refeição. Sim. Ou será do final
da primeira refeição? É do início da
primeira para início da segunda. Doutor,
tenho hipotiroidismo e do mal por causa
da pideia. Minha mina é açúrico que
estavam altos no último exame. Insulindo
um pouco alto também. Estou tomando por
ano, fazendo academia. Mudei minha
dieta, continuo com memória fraca, sem
energia, cansaço crônico, estressado,
estou tomando D3, K2, selena lá. Isso
melhorou bastante, mas não estou 100%.
Vez ou outra sinto tontura quando agacho
e levanto.
O que pode ser?
Bem, apneia do sono e pioidismo juntos,
eles criam um ciclo vicioso. A pneia
aumenta aisteína
de maneira independente, o
hipotiroidismo aumenta aoscisteína
também e aumenta a resistência à
insulina.
Isso vai piorar a disfunção mitocondrial
e piorar o estresse oxidativo.
E o ácido único comentado também aumenta
a resistência insulínica através de
aumento do estresse oxidativo
mitocondrial.
Então, a combinação de resistência à
insulina com homocistina alta compromete
a função mitocondrial do cérebro. Isso
reduz a neuroplasticidade.
O magnésio e a B12 vão ajudar a baixar
uma cisteína,
mas vai precisar também de metifolato,
não sei se tá tomando. Vai precisar de
BB6 ativa, né? peridoxal cinco fosfato,
aumentar a ingestão hídrica para
controlar o ácido úrico,
reduzir a frutose e purina da dieta,
frutose você vai
ter nos alimentos processados,
industrializados também, tá? Então,
tomar cuidado com isso.
Tratar a pneia do sono com prótese
dentária ou com CPAP
é importante.
A tontura ao levantar deve ser
hipotensão ortostática
e o hipotiroismo acaba contribuindo para
essa pressão baixa quando levanta, né,
essa hipotensão autostática.
Importante
manter adequada a hidratação, importante
manter a quantidade de sal integral
adequada, porque a falta de sal integral
pode contribuir para essa queda de
pressão.
Ser interessante usar meias de
compressão durante os treinos.
Tem que ver se a dose do Purã tá numa
dose adequada.
Então são dicas que eu tô te dando, tá?
Porque eu sei que vai ter gente aqui
nova que entrou tem poucas semanas que
vai achar que eu vou fazer consulta aqui
durante a live. Não vou fazer consulta,
pessoal. Eu vou dar dicas, tá?
Aquele estudo de que jejum de 72 horas
regenera sistema imunológico, você
confirma? Confirmo.
Confirmo sim.
Isso aí é um dado muito
exato.
Jovem menos de 30 anos que tem hábito de
lá e viciado fica funcionando em fotos.
Fica funcionando. Que que é isso?
Deve ser que tá olhando as fotos do
Instagram sensuais e aí tá descascando
lá. né? E vídeos de mesmo teor, mas não
vê pornografia explícita e tem curvatura
que provavelmente
é perunura
congênita. Peroni não dá em jovem de 30
anos. Geralmente não dá. Ele sofre de
potência sexual na sua visão.
Tá, ele deixa eu ver se eu entendi, tá
mal formulado aqui. Ele está afirmando
que ele sofre de potência sexual. É isso
ou tá perguntando?
Tá, vou entender aqui que você tá
dizendo que ele tem potência sexual
e acha que pode ser por causa da
masturbação. Tem alguns estudos que
falam que sim.
Desculpa falar essas palavras, pessoal,
mas aí quem for mais sensível me
desculpe. Tentando responder a pergunta
aqui.
Então sim,
existe uns estudos mostrando que jovens
viciados, né, nessa atividade aí
eles podem causar uma espécie de
disfunção
do da circuitaria
de estímulos, né, cerebrais e aí eles
não conseguem mais ter uma estimulação
sexual adequada numa relação normal,
porque aí eles assistem os vídeos com
aquelas atrizes lá e aqueles atores que
não são representações aí da média da
população. E o cara fica com essa
disfunção por conta de tá vendo mulheres
deslumbrantes
e o próprio estímulo da própria mão, né?
E fica viciado com aquilo lá e não
consegue ter o mesmo prazer na na
atividade sexual convencional, tá? Tem
estudos mostrando isso sim. Existe essa
situação, é real, não é fantasia.
e tem que passar por um tratamento
psicológico. Pessoal, já estamos com
1:20, tá? 1 h 20. Eu não vou responder
as dúvidas ao vivo, OK? Só as
relacionadas às perguntas do documento.
Pode usar também durante o voo, tá? as
meias de compressão
e mas é principalmente durante o treino.
Obrigado, Cláudia pela pelo comentário.
Às vezes eu fico preocupado que eu tô
aborrecendo vocês aí.
Não, não tem a ver com ferritina não.
Ouve abacate.
Isso que eu já respondi.
Isso aqui eu também já respondi.
Esse aqui já respondi.
Isso aqui eu já respondi.
É, gente, vamos encerrar, né? Então, com
1 hora 20 de vídeo.
Pessoal, muito obrigado aí pela
participação de vocês
e nós nos vemos na próxima semana,
OK?
Beijo no coração.
E assim, na semana que vem eu vou ser
mais rápido, tá? Eu vou ser mais
suscinto nas perguntas, aliás, nas
respostas, porque tá aumentando o número
de participantes e o número de
perguntas, tá bom? E eu vou ver como é
que ficou
lá o documento lá, se vocês preferem que
a gente faça desse mesmo jeito ou se a
gente começa a selecionar as perguntas.
Abraço para vocês, até a próxima.